foreign
briefly and we're going to pause it a
few times so so stay with us this is a
very popular and viral Tick Tock and and
this is a real sentiment
I want you to understand something we're
not about to show you this and Destroy
and criticize and belittle the sentiment
we will take issue with some things
factually but understand and I want to
set this up properly there are millions
and millions of Americans George Who
feel the way that this gentleman feels
so you take this with a Shaker of salt
and understand this is why we do what we
do here at Ramsey Solutions let's roll
the video
if you're making less than 25 an hour
right now you should be terrified if you
are making less than 25 you're going to
be very pissed off by the time we get to
the end of this video all right this
information here is going to scare all
right pause first of all okay what he
just said there is not true you'll be
fine if you're making 25 an hour we
don't go viral on Tick Tock without some
fear-mongering Ken boys scare the whoop
out of you he said you're not gonna
sleep tonight if you make less than 25
bucks an hour okay this is absolute
nonsense but a lot of people feel this
way all right now George will tell you
how we can do this later let's keep
going
I just spent some time looking at some
monthly averages of regular costs of
living all across the U.S average costs
and I put them all in a spreadsheet and
did all the math for you so you can see
exactly what this big picture is here so
these are just normal expenses that most
single consumers have and this is all of
them laid out national average right
here the average cost of an apartment is
16.59 a month where groceries you're
gonna spend 500 bucks on that and go
down a list here but add all that up
you're looking at 32.85 a month just in
your cost of living expenses which means
to break even pause now George I'm gonna
let you step in here but I pointed this
out on my show we're already uh we're
already a little bit out of whack here
uh when you look at just the the average
vehicle payment the average used car
payment is just a shade under 700 a
month insane so so we're not even
working with real numbers here all right
and and and and then let's just point
out that what if you didn't have that
car payment how far would that go one
thousand percent well one of the reasons
people don't have margin is because they
are living with payments giving all of
their hard-earned money to lenders every
month and they think well this is the
path this is how I get Financial Freedom
this is what success looks like but we
teach no debt pay for things with cash
get reasonable used cars and so this is
a big part of the picture of why there's
no margin in this person's budget that's
right and that's why I pointed this out
America he's saying you can't make
enough this whole video is if you should
be making way more than 25 an hour which
by the way I'm for that that's what I
spent a lot of my time doing helping
people make really good money but to say
that you're the man is keeping you down
when we don't even have the car payment
correctly put in this budget and people
think that that's just something they've
got to carry around so all right let's
keep rolling and just squeeze by
paycheck to paycheck you have to be
making 32.85 every four weeks so this is
calculated at your monthly income at a
40 hour work week so it's your hourly
rate times 160 hours for four weeks in a
month so I don't believe anybody should
have to work more than a 40 hour week
just to survive now this tax column
represents how much you'd be paying each
month in taxes after you add up all your
withholdings I figured this out by
looking at my pay subs from the last
time I was an employee about six years
ago so you got your gross income you got
your net income after you pay this tax
which would go in this column and fill
it all in the first time you see a
number higher than this number is at
twenty five dollars an hour it could
even get worse than that because chances
are you're going to be paying more than
16 in total withholdings and anything
like child support or alimony to that
and forget about it so this leads you
with very limited options you either
have to kill yourself working way way
too many hours or you've got to figure
out a way to make a ton of money pause
so there's all those two options Ken all
right George that's what I wanted you to
weigh in on that because I I wait on
this on my show but this is a false
Choice kill yourself most people lose
hope because they back themselves into a
corner and decide there's only two
choices Ken either kill myself working
jobs I I hate or uh that's it that's it
this is the only path yeah so you looked
at the spreadsheet nothing there's no
advice in this Tick Tock about
controlling spending no so what issues
do you have if you're just listening
you're not seeing the spreadsheet but
outlined here the first number is rent
at 1659 which he claims is the average
rent uh in the U.S I don't buy that now
if you're on the coast you're in some
higher cost of living cities yes but let
me tell you Ken if this is based on a
single person let's say a single young
guy right that's kind of who he's
talking to in this video well I was not
living by myself in a nice apartment
when I was a single young guy in my
entry-level job I had a roommate you
might have multiple roommates and so to
be paying 1659 is insane I would say
well time to get a roommate that cuts
your rent down to 8.25 and it just gave
you 800 in margin back in your life
now let's pay off that car because
you're paying 400 bucks a month towards
that car payment or you sell the car
that's an extra 400 back in our life now
look what happens Ken we have an extra
twelve hundred dollars of margin that we
can breathe don't forget the streaming
he's got 37 down for streaming yeah
yes and so there are ways to trim the
budget the question are what are you
what are you willing to do because don't
tell me you can't don't tell me you
can't get a roommate say you're
unwilling to get a roommate and this is
for a short period of time we're
sacrificing number one Ken would say
well we can help you get your income up
that's right if you don't have enough to
make ends meet because of your cost of
living
and by the way forty thousand dollars
can go a long way in Idaho and it may
not go a long way in L.A and there's the
other part of the narrative so the one
is kill yourself working crazy amounts
of hours or go have to make more money
like that's a bad thing if the way it's
positioned is like oh get a job where
you make more money oh like have to bust
it I can't quiet quit right I got I got
instead of quiet quitting how about some
uh gritty greatness George oh how about
that that's a new one I know what he's
talking about that well can we know this
and we're confident about it because we
meet people every day Main Street folks
who come to our debt free stage and
guess what for a short period of time
they worked extra they worked more than
40 hours a week they work 60 hours a
week because they wanted to sacrifice
for a short time instead of being in
pain for a long time which is where most
of America finds themselves living in
mediocrity for 20 years because they
don't want to sacrifice for two which by
the way is the average amount of time it
takes for our folks to get out of debt
I'm gonna tell you where this kind of
this kind and again a lot of people feel
this I get it but when it's positioned
as though you are a victim and this
video whether meant to be made this way
or not is all about making the person
who watched this video feel like a
victim
as opposed to saying wait a second you
don't have to accept this
this isn't some sentence this may be a
season of your life but it's not a life
sentence the hamster wheel is not your
miserable plot that somebody more
powerful than you has bestowed upon you
yeah
believing that it can be different and
then
actions that lead you towards Freedom
long term and that's exactly what we do
we have a solution we're not just trying
to rile you up about the problem we want
to show you a way out show you hope
instead of these hope Stealers out there
telling you it's everyone else's problem
and you're not the solution this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]